- It's so hot.
Only the sun burns.
- [Mark] So Valerie
- Yeah.
- [Mark] How long you been
down here on Skid Row?
- Wow. Got a great piece.
- 20 years.
- [Mark] 20 years. And where
are you from originally?
- Boyle Heights
- [Mark] So East LA?
- Yep. My son was, he's 22, so
- [Mark] Your son is 22?
- Mm-hm. My daughter's 32. Yeah.
- [Mark] And where do you sleep at night?
- In a tent.
- [Mark] Right here,
right down the street?
- Mm-hm.
- [Mark] What is your drug
of choice here on the street?
- Well, she was taken cause SRLs
aren't the same for (mumble)
and I was in recovery
and they took my house,
and my son,
and my husband, everything.
And I've been here ever since.
- [Mark] Recovery from what?
- Recovery, in recovery.
- [Mark] But which drug?
- All of them, any.
(laughter)
- [Mark] Did you do any at all?
- Not anymore.
- [Mark] Which is your favorite?
- M A
- [Mark] I'm sorry?
- Drugs Addicts Anonymous.
- [Mark] But which drugs
were your favorite?
- Any of them.
- [Mark] It doesn't matter?
- Uh-uh.
I don't use one or the
other, they all hold hands.
Is that all right?
- [Mark] Yes.
- I don't use cocaine anymore.
- [Mark] Why not?
- 'Cause the earth starts moving.
(laughter)
If I take a hit, the swoosh swoosh.
So I, that's...
- [Mark] And what do you do for money?
- Praise God (laughing)
- [Mark] Do you pick up men sometimes?
- No. I recycle.
- [Mark] You recycle?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] You see your son?
- Yeah. He's in jail right now.
- [Mark] He's in jail? What for?
- I don't know, but he's
supposed to be getting out soon
and he's been a lot, you know, but he's
she'll be getting out and
it just, I don't know.
It's kinda hot in here.
- [Mark] Yeah. We'll be quick.
- It's a long story, you know?
- [Mark] Tell me.
- Yeah. It's 'cause when
they took my son, you know
we weren't married and recovery
he relapsed and then they
took everything from me.
So, I was in jail because
he had drugs in the house
and then took my son, and
then they took all my stuff
and my house
and then they put me in prison
and then all my stuff
got taken away from me,
so, and my son too.
And then my husband left me
here downtown at the Wine Cart.
So I haven't seen him ever since.
And my son, I hadn't seen for 10 years
and he barely came
started coming to see
me when he turned 18.
And then he went to jail.
So, I don't know.
And I've never depended on nobody.
I've never had this much problems
in my life, but I've always been
self-supporting taking care of myself
you know, I don't, I don't
go with bed because I'd feel
that it would to myself
demeaning that people shouldn't
ever think about each
other like that, you know?
But I can't change everyone
or anything without God, so
you know, a lot of times
it's just real stressful
because there's really nobody to talk to.
They really don't want
to talk about real things
because they're trying
to evade it, you know.
But I said you can't evade it,
it's going to be there
in the end, you know?
I never cried before
and that's what almost killed me
was an emotional breakdown, you know,
I was only supposed serious,
get my life together
you know, and have some kids
and someone in my life.
I have to take, try to make
sure my mom would be okay
'Cause he didn't have a good husband
and my grandma because she
didn't have one at all,
you know?
And then women with children,
that's how I learned
that women with children
other men don't want them,
and especially if they have more children
with different men, you know?
So my grandma had three,
from three different fathers
and my mom had only had one,
so I saw that
and then, so I waited
10 years to have my kids
'cause I wasn't, it's a long story.
Can I've some tissue please?
I'm sorry (crying)
Thank-you. I apologize.
- [Mark] It's okay.
This is not even, this
is not even my behavior
you know, acting human, you know, but...
- [Mark] It's dangerous out
here on the street, are you...
- Yeah. But we're all dangerous, you know,
especially Jesus, you know,
he's the one I worry about the most.
I don't want to get into too much (crying)
Yeah, so being here, I just
try to take care of myself
and do the best that I can
without getting into too much,
but people just don't
understand how not to steal,
oh my God,
you shouldn't steal.
He says don't steal for a reason people,
you know what I mean?
Could drive some crazy, you know?
And seeing you stealing from your salary
like nobody else, you know, so.
- [Mark] Did you have a job
once when you were married?
- Oh yeah.
- [Mark] What were you doing?
- A receptionist. I worked
for job court typing stuff.
Yeah. I had jobs.
I tried to work for the dog catcher
but I think they have spirituality rules.
I didn't, I didn't know nothing
about spirituality 'til I got here
so I kind of dues by that, you know?
Ooh it's hot. You need a fan in here too.
(Laughter)
Yeah, I got one too. I'll
bring it to you, okay?
But like, I don't really choose...
- [Mark] Well Valerie, thank-you so much
for talking to me.
- Oh you're welcome.
I'm gonna need a bath.
- [Mark] Be safe out there.
- Okay, thank-you.